Hey Wisecrack, Jared again.
We got some really encouraging comments from
our Suicide Squad autopsy, so we’re trying
it again.
This time we’re diving into the trenches
with my latest time-suck: Battlefield 1.
Just a note here, we’re not out to tell
you whether or not Battlefield is fun (it
is), or if it’s historically accurate (it’s
not), or if snipers are ruining the game (they
might be).
We’re here, instead, in good Wisecrackian
fashion, to delve into the brains of the game.
Battlefield 1 does something that most of
its predecessors never dared to do, and that
was to say something.
Now, saying something in a game that’s 90%
getting taunted by 12 year olds
"...and piss off!"
is difficult, but Battlefield tries nonetheless.
But does it succeed in saying something?
Well, let’s find out!
Welcome to this Wisecrack autopsy of Battlefield 1.
Spoiler alert for old War movies that you
probably should have have seen already anyway.
But first, some context.
Setting Battlefield in the First World War
is more meaningful than you might think.
Of course, you could say the creators chose
The Great War because they’d run out of
modern wars after exhausting World War 2,
Vietnam, the present day, the future -- and
you wouldn’t be wrong.
However, I’d like to argue that Battlefield
1’s setting provides really fascinating
insights into contemporary politics and how
we think about war.
If you grew up around the same time I did,
your childhood probably meant weeks of hunkering
down in front of a TV to avoid the sun and
murder Nazis.
So - many - Nazis.
This was an era marked by games like Call
of Duty, Medal of Honor, and, of course, Battlefield
1942.
World War 2 is a media darling for a reason.
No matter where you land on the political
spectrum, we can all agree who the good guys
were, and who the bad guys were.
And while World War 2 has been, and will likely
continue to be, a hugely popular inspiration
for media, it was really popular in the early
2000s.
I don’t think this is entirely coincidental.
Call of Duty released in 2003, the same year
the United States invaded Iraq.
Medal of Honor, which launched in ‘99, released
8 of their 11 titles in the four years following
the start of the Iraq War.
Battlefield 1942 released in September 2002,
the same month George Bush formally called
for the ousting of Saddam Hussein and a year
after the US declared a “war on terror”
in response to 9/11.
Meanwhile, this era saw hugely popular movies
like Saving Private Ryan, which went on to
inspire Medal of Honor: Allied Assault, Enemy
at the Gates, Pearl Harbor, and the HBO miniseries
Band of Brothers.
World War 2 caters to everyone’s needs.
For the proponents of the War on Terror and
the Iraq War, which was, at its onset, the
vast majority of people, World War 2 affirms
the story of America-as-savior-of-the-world.
We restored freedom to Europe, and we’re
back to do it again.
"America, f*ck yeah!"
And for those against
America’s continued involvement in the Middle
East, World War 2 provided a comforting escape
to the good ol’ days when good and evil
were as clear as black and white.
"There are no good wars, with the following exceptions:
The American Revolution, World War 2, and the Star Wars Trilogy."
So what does any of this have to do with Battlefield
1?
World War I has never, in recent memory, been
a popular war for media.
But all the sudden it’s featured by a huge
franchise.
What makes this war resonate with gamers now?
Sure its in the midst of its centennial, but it was
a war where millions didn’t even die in
the glory of battle, but from disease; a war
where there are really no good guys or bad guys.
Given our current shift in opinion about American
interventionism,
we no longer see our wars as conflict between
good and evil akin to World War 2, but as
a futile tragedy akin to World War 1.
This sense of tragedy is bolstered throughout
the game by its use of pathos.
Pathos is a Greek word for “suffering, feeling,
emotion, calamity,” and, for Aristotle,
is one of the three modes of persuasion.
For a game that’s mostly about its multiplayer,
Battlefield finds a lot of ways to inject
pathos.
And not just the usual “sacrifice for the
greater good” kind, either.
"All we got out here's blind orders - and chance."
For one, instead of infinitely respawning
in the prologue, we’re told that we are
“Not expected to survive.”
We’re launched into a gray, bleak hellscape,
where every time you die, you’re shown the
name, birth and death dates of the soldier
who just died.
Rather than presenting an endless series of
faceless deaths, the game gives the player
a feeling of pity for the soldiers, and emphasizes
the fact that each death is an individual
human tragedy.
These mini-obituaries share something with
the original war story — The Iliad — in
which Homer provides a mini obituary for almost
every character that dies, no matter how minor,
in order to make sure the reader doesn’t
forget the cost of battle.
As thinker Jasper Griffin argues, while many
stories use the “countless insignificant
dead” as nothing more than a “mighty number
for the hero to slay,” the Iliad draws emotion
from the deaths of even the most insignificant
heroes.
In a genre that thrives on hordes of faceless
people to kill - Battlefield 1 sets itself
apart by forcing us to confront the actual
human toll of the war.
Even the loading scenes of Operations mode
don’t provide a coherent narrative so much
as explore the emotional lives of soldiers
from both sides: The hollow optimism of Brits
fighting the Ottomans
and American doughboys fighting the Germans,
And the inevitable confrontation with the
horrors of war.
Battlefield set itself up in a great place:
showcasing the hopes, thoughts and dreams
of soldiers during a war fraught with moral
ambiguity.
In the prologue, we see a Harlem Hellfighter
facing off with a German soldier.
They both lower their weapons in resignation.
This sort of thing happened more than you
might realize.
You’ve probably heard of the Christmas Truce,
where soldiers from opposing armies stopped
murdering each other and even exchanged gifts.
So, awesome.
Battlefield sets itself up to explore this
dynamic in its campaign; that Unlike World
War II, we the audience are a little more
primed to feel for the opposing side.
But Battlefield quickly abandons this in the
bulk of the single player.
As soon as you move on to another war story,
you’re faced with actual faceless NPCs for
you to mow down, and fair enough - feeling
sad for the enemy doesn’t make for very
exciting gameplay in an first person shooter.
But if we had our Wisecrack way, it would
be really interesting if the theme embodied
in the Hellfighter stand-off was further developed
in the game.
We see similar confrontations explored in
film.
In World War 1 classics like “Paths of Glory”
and “All Quiet on the Western Front,”
the bad guy is not the enemy, but the war
itself is.
In “All Quiet on The Western Front,” a
soldier is met with horrible remorse when
he stabs an enemy combatant in a foxhole.
In “Paths of Glory,” a captured German
woman is berated by a bunch of rowdy soldiers
before they’re overtaken by the beauty of
her voice.
The arbitrary division of humanity melts away
as soldiers join her in song.
This is one of my favorite scenes in all of cinema.
In World War 2, however, the bad guy is...the
bad guy.
Saving Private Ryan, for instance, shows us
an act of mercy gone wrong: After Upham finds
camaraderie with his German enemy, he gets
his friends killed.
This fact forces Upham to reevaluate his view
of war, and of Germans.
Despite featuring some stories from the Central
Powers in some of the loading scenes, only
Allies are playable in the campaign.
This is a tragedy, because the interactivity
of video games can provide an unprecedented
amount of depth to these kinds of narratives.
What do the stories being told in Battlefield
look like from the eyes of a German or an Ottoman
soldier?
Rather than diving into any of the interesting
themes the game sets up, such as: the world’s first
“industrial” war, its morally ambiguous
nature, and the human cost of battle, we’re
instead given generic stories about self sacrifice
and personal growth.
Video games are an incredible art form, one
with tons of untapped potential.
And yeah, I get it, the game is about yelling
at people to play the fucking objective.
But the creators of Battlefield 1 tried to
do something insightful, and for that, we
commend them.
If you make games and are watching this, please
do more of this.
But if you’re a lowly gamer like us looking
for a great game that explores the psychological
impact and moral ambiguity of war: play Spec
Ops: The Line. Thanks for watching guys! Peace!